so as I've been walking around Munich I
keep seeing people with surfboards and
I'm like listen I'm not a geographer but
where's the ocean there's the ocean I'm
coming to you today in a field of
sunflowers because well because I can
let's walk
showing in your video on Wednesday you
discussed an encounter with Snooki a
reality television show star I sort of
knew who Snooki was but I wasn't totally
confident so after I watched your video
I went to check her out on Twitter and
Hank what I discovered troubled me it's
raining let's go inside now I think a
lot of people say that grammar and
spelling aren't that important and
certainly their importance can be
exaggerated but the reason grammar and
spelling exist is to make communicative
experiences as clear and transparent as
possible so today Hank we're gonna look
at some recent Snooki tweets to see how
poor grammar and spelling can lead to
confusion and threesomes
Snooki tweets everyone stop having heart
attacks when I miss an apostrophe or
coma or period don't want to pop a blood
vessel in your eyeballs okay first off
Snooki I'm not the one who should be
concerned when you miss a period
secondly I'm certainly sympathetic to
the occasional apostrophe mistake but I
am deeply concerned when anyone misses a
coma
I mean Snooki I realized that you are
not a trained medical professional but
still comas should be relatively easy to
spot the only excuse for missing a coma
is being in a coma another example
Snooki tweets I wish I didn't freeze up
when I saw Mark Wahlberg at the MTV
Movie Awards because he is so bangin FML
mark comeback wall let me submit that
Mark Wahlberg might be somewhat more
inclined to believe that you are a big
fan if you knew that he spelled his name
with a K and now Hank let's move on to
the equally troubling problem of poor
grammar no I'm gonna look past the small
stuff like the fact that Snooki
repeatedly refers to groups of men as
packs of gorillas even though we all
know that a group of gorillas is called
a troop I'm not even going to get into
these strange and fascinating the racist
habit of calling your followers tweet
OHS but Hank check this out
Snooki tweets I like pink roses and long
walks on the beach and holding your hand
with margaritas and the other this time
of year huh hey this is a very difficult
set of two parts but so far as I can
tell there are
possibilities first possibility Snooki
has freakishly large hands that allow
her to hold her boyfriend's hand with
one hand and plural margaritas with the
other hand possibility number 2 Snooki
has more than two hands at least three
possibly many more so that she has one
hand with which to hold her boyfriend's
hand and then two or more hands with
which to hold margaritas and lastly and
most disturbingly possibility number
three given Snooki's hatred of
apostrophes and capitalizations it is
possible that Snooki is imagining some
kind of menage tois
with her boyfriend and a woman named
margarita as in this time of year I like
pink roses long walks on the beach and
holding your hand with margaritas in the
other Hey this is why grammar is
important because without it we can't
tell if Snooki is polyamorous Liam kind
whereas a secret third hand nothing I
want to emphasize that Snooki is not
stupid we all make spelling mistakes I
mean you misspelled Snooki's name in
your Wednesday video and although it's
my job not to I make grammatical
mistakes all the time but Snooki doesn't
value language and she doesn't care
about the quality of discourse in our
society and I wonder when we celebrate
those people instead of people who use
language precisely and thoughtfully then
we end up with really crappy discourse
whether it's on the Jersey Shore or in
Congress tank munich is lovely my
punishment sounds horrible so thanks for
that nerdfighters please keep suggesting
punishments for Hank in comments I read
them all Hank you'll find out your
punishment on Wednesday but I'll see you
first on Monday best wishes